[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen in einen
norbert lehmann ist auch wieder dabei
für den sport guten abend die regierung
scholz verliert ihre erste ministerin
ein erzwungener rücktritt
familienministerin spiegel muss ihren
hut nehmen weil fehler in der
vergangenheit sie einholen
ein umstrittenes treffen österreichs
kanzler ne hammer ist der erste eu
politiker seit kriegsbeginn der
russlands präsident putin persönlich zum
frieden drängt
und corona testzentren unter verdacht
während die meisten ordnungsgemäß
abrechnen gibt es bundesweit bereits
mehr als 600 verfahren wegen betrugs
ihr umgang mit der flutkatastrophe wurde
ihr zum verhängnis da half auch keine
entschuldigung mehr an der spiegel ist
als bundesfamilienministerin
zurückgetreten das ende einer steilen
politischen karriere
im dezember wurde die grüne als eine der
jüngsten ministerin im kabinett
vereidigt zuvor war die vierfache mutter
im rheinland pfalz umweltministerin
während der flutkatastrophe
gestern abend noch versuchte die 41
jährige mit einem emotionalen auftritt
zu erklären warum sie kurz nach der flut
lange urlaub machte mathis feldhoff
berichtet
es ist ein irritierender auftritt am
gestrigen abend mit einer letzten
stellungnahme versucht
familienministerin spiegel ihre
politische karriere zu retten 18 stunden
später tritt sie mit einer kurzen
schriftlichen erklärung zurück aufgrund
des politischen drucks wie sie schreibt
kurz nach der verheerenden flut im
aartal bei der sie noch als
rheinland-pfälzische umweltministerin
verantwortung trägt war sie in einen
vierwöchigen urlaub gefahren es war ein
fehler dass wir
auch so langen urlaub gefahren sind und
dass wir in urlaub gefahren sind
und ich bitte
für diesen fehler
um entschuldigung zutiefst persönlich
ist ihr auftritt sie macht
gesundheitliche probleme ihres mannes
und belastungen der familie öffentlich
die solidarität der grünen parteispitze
bleibt dennoch auffällig passiv was die
pressekonferenz von einer spiegel angeht
würde ich für möchte ich gerne für mich
sagen dass sie unter die haut gegangen
ist das glaube ich ging also die es
gesehen haben mit dem heutigen tag ist
für sie nicht nur politisch sondern auch
persönlich
einen weg beschritten wurden der glaube
ich deutlich macht wie brutal politik
sein kann gerade aus der grünen partei
heraus hatte es massiven druck auf
spiegel gegeben dem gibt sie jetzt nach
der
schritt jetzt nun zurück zu treten ist
bei aller
großen herzen und so schwierig diese
entscheidung auch war richtig wir danken
ihr sehr für diese entscheidung dafür
dass die verantwortung genommen hat er
ist zeichnet sich das bild einer
ministerin die an ihre persönlichen
grenzen gestoßen war auch die behauptung
sie habe während ihres urlaubs online an
kabinettssitzungen teilgenommen muss sie
korrigieren
ich habe nicht aus meinem urlaub heraus
an den kabinettssitzungen teilgenommen
aber ich möchte betonen dass sich die
ganze zeit erreichbar bei der
bundeskanzlerin nimmt den rücktritt an
die grünen wollen schnell einen
vorschlag für die nachfolge machen
theo koll in berlin man fragt sich jetzt
warum anne spiegel sich und ihrer
familie diesen auftritt gestern nicht
erspart hat
also die einzig schlüssige annahme
scheint mir zu sein dass frau spiegel
versucht hat mit diesen privaten
informationen und der geschilderten
familiär notlage ihren politischen kopf
und die ram zu retten ihr privatleben
sollte ganz offensichtlich als
entschuldigung für ihr politisches
fehlverhalten nähe halten den
beruflichen preis zahlt sie jetzt
dennoch den privaten hat sie zusätzlich
ihrer familie aufgebürdet indem sie
extrem vertrauliche details über einen
schlaganfall und über corona
folgeschäden vor der nation öffentlich
gemacht hat das muss dem ganzen eine
weitgehende mentale überforderung zu
grunde liegen frau spiegel hat
offensichtlich nicht erkannt dass
angesichts des unendlichen leid der
menschen im aartal die persönliche
situation der zuständigen ministerin
nicht als entschuldigung dienen kann
was bedeutet dieser rücktritt herz für
die grünen und für die regierung
und für die us-regierung ist es vier
monate nach antritt ein politischer
gesichtsverlust neben dem rücktritt von
frau spiegel gelten ja mittlerweile auch
zwei weitere kabinettsmitglieder
lambrecht und lauterbach als angezählte
kandidaten und die grünen stellt der
rücktritt einer frau vom linken flügel
der partei vor ein schier unlösbares
problem einerseits müsste um auch die
geschlechter balance zu halten wieder
eine linke frau in die regierung auf
steigen andererseits soll anton
hofreiter das versprechen in der tasche
haben der erste nachrücker zu sein
sollte ein grüner platz im kabinett frei
werden aber vielleicht entscheidet auch
einfach qualifikation
nach berlin
fragen rund um spiegels amtsverzicht
beantworten wir online und in unserer
zdf heute app dort gibt es eine
zusammenfassung der ereignisse von den
vorwürfen bis zu ihrem rücktritt
zum krieg in der ukraine die eu plant
weitere sanktionen gegen russland über
ein öl-embargo berieten heute die
außenminister es ging aber auch um die
lieferung schwerer waffen an tiere
bundes außenministerin baerbock ist
dafür aus luxemburg anne gellinek
immer mehr bilder der zerstörung kommen
aus den ortschaften rund um kiew die von
der russischen armee geräumt wurden in
buddy anka westlich der ukrainischen
hauptstadt klafft eine gigantische lücke
in ein wohnblock unterdessen melden die
prorussischen separatisten dass sie
einen teil der hafenstadt mario pohl
unter ihre kontrolle gebracht hätten die
stadt scheint fast völlig verwüstet
solche bilder und die mutmasslicher
kriegsverbrechen an zivilisten haben ein
umdenken in europa beim thema
waffenlieferungen bewirkt die deutsche
außenministerin ist nun dafür die
ukraine braucht weiteres militärisches
material vor allen dingen auch schwere
waffen und jetzt ist keine zeit für
ausreden sondern jetzt ist zeit für
kreativität und pragmatismus details
nannte bock nicht aber offenbar geht es
um solche veralteten und von der
bundeswehr bereits ausgemusterten
kampfpanzer vom typ leopard 1 sie
müssten allerdings zunächst noch
überprüft und gewartet werden auch die
lieferung von marder schützenpanzern und
panzerhaubitzen steht im raum der
ukrainische präsident zealand ski hatte
in seiner nächtlichen rede den
kurswechsel der deutschen regierung
bereits begrüßt und gleichzeitig
schärfere sanktionen gefordert wie zum
beispiel ein embargo gegen russisches öl
darüber allerdings streitet europa noch
die osteuropäer sind dafür deutschland
und einige andere dagegen für
diskussionsstoff sorgt auch die reise
des österreichischen kanzlers zugleich
die mir putin nach moskau es ist der
erste besuch eines europäischen
regierungschefs seit kriegsbeginn jede
stimme die den verbänden putin
verdeutlicht wie die realität sich
außerhalb der mauern des kreml ist
wirklich darstellt ist keine verlorene
stimme
ich persönlich glaube nicht dass wir mit
ihm sprechen sollten es sei denn über
seine strafrechtliche verantwortung für
diesen krieg
europa versucht eine doppelstrategie
dialog mit un sanktionen gegen russland
und gleichzeitig waffenlieferungen an
die ukraine
axel sturm steht vor der residenz des
österreichischen botschafters in moskau
wo gerade der kanzler auftrat axel was
hat dieses treffen gebracht es sollte er
auf keinen fall putin eine bühne bieten
nein das war schon ein kernanliegen
keine große diplomatische bühne keine
bilder für die welt kein anzeichen
darauf hin dass man sich ernährt an den
russischen staatspräsidenten und dennoch
war es dem österreichischen
bundeskanzler offenbar doch ein
dringliches anliegen mit ihm zu sprechen
was hat er getan er hat vor wenigen
minuten erklärt er sei nicht sonderlich
optimistisch nach den gesprächen seine
kernaussage sei gewesen dass er putin
dazu aufgefordert habe ein ende der wie
sie hier heißt sogenannten militärischen
spezialoperation herbeizuführen ob das
gelingt steht in den sternen vom kreml
gibt es bislang noch kein statement
axel sturm live aus moskau dankeschön
ja trotz dialog und druck vor allem im
osten der ukraine gehen die kämpfe
weiter neben mario pohl besonders unter
beschuss ist kharkiv am nachmittag wurde
dort ein wohnviertel angegriffen fünf
menschen sollen getötet worden sein auch
ein kind trotz der gefahr sind in
kharkiv unermüdlich helfer im einsatz
und journalisten wie arndt ginzel der
sie begleitet hatte
das rote kreuz in hartz iv die helfer
bereiten einen einsatz vor sie verpacken
windeln hygieneartikel medikamente für
die menschen in den umkämpften gebieten
es war geplant dass wir heute in prag
hilfe leisten und auch menschen
evakuieren wir haben dafür drei autos
vorbereitet und dann mussten wir aber
alles abblasen weil dort gekämpft wird
und weil dort panzer stehen
wie gefährlich die fahrten durch vaqif
sind sehen wir an den krankenwagen
selbst das rote kreuz gerät hier unter
beschuss
dann steigt plötzlich rauch auf über der
stadt in einem wohnviertel in der nähe
ist eine rakete eingeschlagen dieses
einfamilienhaus ist völlig zerstört
eine straße weiter noch ein einschlag
der russische angriff hat menschenleben
gekostet
mein mann wurde getötet er saß auf einer
bank dann ist das geschoss eingeschlagen
ich weiß nicht was es war
morgen wollten wir nach polen ausreisen
und das ist jetzt daraus geworden
ein paar meter weiter von dem haus vor
dem noch der verstorbene zivilist liegt
finden wir eine rakete die jetzt gerade
eben hier eingeschlagen und hat
todesopfer gefordert mehrere menschen
sind verletzt die angriffe auf fragt eve
nehmen zu und fordern immer mehr zivile
opfer
nach frankreich weil dort gestern kein
kandidat für das präsidentenamt die
absolute mehrheit bekam geht es in zwei
wochen in die stichwahl und die ist auch
für europa entscheidend
amtsinhaber makro holte im ersten
durchgang die meisten stimmen
27,8 prozent seine gegnerin am sonntag
in zwei wochen die rechtspopulistin
marine le pen kommt auf 23,2 prozent nur
knapp geschlagen der linkspopulist
jean-luc melange mit 22 prozent aus
paris thomas walde
nach dem wahlkampf ist vor dem wahlkampf
immer nur marc rom besucht heute den
arbeiter gegend und demonstriert stunden
lang die bürgernähe die er bisher
vermissen ließ gut france-presse viele
franzosen wollen ja gerne für sie im
zweiten wahlgang stimmen aber sie müssen
ihnen sicherheit geben herr präsident es
tut mir leid
ich stimme ihnen dazu man darf aber
keine sicherheit vorgaukeln mit falschen
versprechungen es braucht ernsthafte
bemühungen
makros gegnerin in der stichwahl marine
le pen will die unzufriedenen hinter
sich versammeln ihr hauptthema bleibt
die kaufkraft
die inflation liegt nicht hinter uns
sondern vor und sie ist eine last die
die regierung nicht sehen will
viel wird davon abhängen wie seine
anhänger sich entscheiden der linke jörg
müller chance verpasste knapp den einzug
in die stichwahl
und nun
keine einzige stimme für madame le pen
will ruft indessen nicht dazu auf nun
makro zu wählen und bei seinen anhängern
sind lippen und makro verhasst
die ehemals regierenden parteien der
republik und der sozialisten landeten
unter fünf prozent und kämpfen um das
politische überleben eine
stichwahl wie 2017 also und doch ist
frankreichs politische landschaft
radikal verändert das nationalistische
lager stärker als je zuvor und der
wahlkampf ist noch nicht vorbei
die europäische union beendet vorerst
ihre militärische ausbildungsmission im
westafrikanischen mali das kündigte der
eu außenbeauftragte borel an zuletzt
trainierten unter anderem rund 300
deutsche soldaten malische armee
angehörige im kampf gegen terrorgruppen
in mali hatte das militär die macht
übernommen und zuletzt auch russische
söldner engagiert
immer wieder ist die hessische polizei
im fokus der justiz wegen beamten die in
chat gruppen rechtsextreme bilder und
videos austauschen erst vor wenigen
tagen ist eine in darmstadt aufgeflogen
von 2014 bis 2018 gab es eine solche
gruppe auch bei der frankfurter polizei
heute erhob die staatsanwaltschaft
anklage fünf beamten wird vorgeworfen in
einem chat rechtsextremistische und
menschenverachtende inhalte geteilt zu
haben
jetzt zur corona pandemie da singt die
bundesweite sieben tage incident zweiter
und liegt nun bei
1080 dem robert koch institut wurden 30
1789 neue fälle innerhalb eines tages
gemeldet 10 1340 weniger als vergangenen
montag
manche bereichern sich an dieser
pandemie so gibt es mittlerweile an
jeder ecke testzentren aber nicht alle
sind seriös mehr als
640 verfahren wegen betrugs gibt es
bundesweit gegen solche zentren es geht
um falsche abrechnungen aber auch um
auffallend geringe corona trefferquoten
der schaden soll im hohen zweistelligen
millionenbereich liegen aus stuttgart
berichten petra otto und jan frederik
fischer
einmal abstreichen mehrfach abrechnen
wohl keine seltenheit und für die täter
lukrativ bei 11 eur 50 protest vom staat
die staatsanwaltschaften ermitteln
bundesweit mindestens
642 verfahren wegen mutmaßlichen
abrechnungsbetrugs auch das
landeskriminalamt baden württemberg hat
alle hände voll zu tun wieso haben wir
festgestellt mehrere hundert solcher
verfahren die auch polizeilich in
bearbeitung sind die schadenshöhen
kümmert derzeit noch nicht genau
beziffern die bewegen sich aber im
oberen millionenbereich hinweise auf
kriminelle strukturen organisierte
kriminalität haben wir derzeit nicht
schwer nachzuweisen wo betrogen wird die
dunkelziffer hoch dazu kommen oft auch
schlechte hygiene standards
unvollständige unterlagen in baden
württemberg haben sie kontrolliert und
gravierende mängel festgestellt bei mehr
als der hälfte der schnelltests zentren
saubere teststationen geraten da unter
generalverdacht bei so vielen schwarzen
schafen wozu braucht es überhaupt an
jeder ecke an schnelltests zentrum jetzt
wo die maßnahmen gelockert sind und kaum
noch nachweise verlangt werden das
glaube ich kann man auf die sukzessive
verzichten das sollten symptomatische
menschen getestet werden dann aber
vernünftig mit einem pcr test und ich
glaube von diesen doch in der qualität
sehr unterschiedlichen
dass es an jeder ecke können wir uns
jetzt langsam verabschieden kostenlose
bürger tests damit soll wohl auch schon
ende mai schluss sein die verfahren
gegen abrechnungsbetrug die laufen noch
lange
und jetzt fußball-champions-league
norbert beginnt morgen für die bayern um
die woche beim viertelfinal rückspiel
gegen villarreal
letzte woche hatte der fcb ja in spanien
0 1 verloren und war damit sogar noch
gut bedient jetzt brauchen die bayern
also im rückspiel daheim einen klaren
sieg es ist die entscheidende phase der
saison und nagelsmann es nerven sind
sichtlich angespannt die vorstellung
gegen augsburg alles andere als eine
geglückte generalprobe wir haben
überhaupt keine führungskrise wir
kommunizieren viel wird über überlegen
uns jedes mal was können wir besser
machen im viertelfinal-hinspiel steckte
der kapitän mit fehlern wie diesem seine
mitspieler an das einzig gute am laut
trainer nagelsmann schlechtesten spiel
seit langem es ging nur 0 zu 1 verloren
nun sollen die erfahrenen wie müller
oder neuer vorangehen die intensität
muss deutlich hochgeschraubt werden das
waren die spieler also zwei drei tagen
an alleine ja nicht mal eine lange
offline ist schon so eine sehr kurze und
jetzt morgen und noch diese silbernen
schnalle vorne aufmachen dann müssen sie
laufen hoffentlich dann alle in eine
richtung und mit größeren schritten
damit das halbfinale noch erreicht
werden kann
morgen gibt es auch spannenden
frauenfußball serbien gegen deutschland
zu sehen bei uns im zdf ab 15 uhr 45 das
dfb team ist heute in belgrad angekommen
und bereitet sich auf das wm quali spiel
vor nach sieben siegen in sieben gruppen
spielen sind die deutschen frauen
natürlich der favorit sollten sie wieder
gewinn ja dann wäre das ticket für die
weltmeisterschaft vorzeitig gelöst
und im letzten sonntagsspiel hat gestern
abend fußball-bundesligist leipzig seine
erfolgsserie fortgesetzt die beste
rückrundenmannschaft gewannen souverän
gegen hoffenheim mit 3 zu 0 und ist als
tabellenvierter weiter auf champions
league kurs domenico tedesco und legt
sich das passt seit er trainer ist hat
der r b 10 von 15 liga spielen gewonnen
und auch gegen hoffenheim gelang das von
beginn an treffer eins nach freistoß
schon in der fünften minute durch
christopher walken bleibt sich
torhungrig hat mit 34 treffern die
meisten tore in dieser runde erzählt
marcel halstenberg mit dem 20 der
verteidiger nach elf monaten
verletzungspause zurück in der startelf
das 3 0 von dominik so mosler besiegelte
dann schon kurz vor der pause den sieg
für leipzig gelungene generalprobe vor
dem europa league rückspiel in bergamo
alle höhepunkte und alle tolles 29
spieltags wir immer zu sehen bei zdf
heute.de und in der zdf- heute apps
eingestellt glaube das wetter macht
freude mit sonne und wärme wie lange das
so bleibt sagt ihn gleich aus dem terry
marietta slomka begrüßt sie um viertel
vor zehn im heute-journal danke für ihr
interesse alles gute ihnen und bis
morgen wenn sie mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon genannte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter auf dem atlantik hat sich ein
tief festgetackert kann man hier sagen
und schiebt immer wieder seine wolken in
unsere richtung bei uns ist hoher
luftdruck und der wird von diesen wolken
gestört aber das tief lenkt auch warme
luft aus nordafrika zu uns und da ist
sogar saharastaub dabei schauen wir in
die nacht und da wird es im osten
aufklaren stern klar wird es hier seien
mit dem hohen luftdruck sonst sind eher
harmlose wolken unterwegs meist hohe
wolken da fällt kein regen heraus und
die temperaturen sinken auf minus vier
grad im osten deutschlands minus ein
grad im südosten und 8 grad am
niederrhein morgen dann vor allem im
süden viel sonne richtungen bayern und
sonst im südwesten ebenfalls hier kann
auch saharastaub dabei sein ansonsten
sind die wolken im norden etwas
kompakter insgesamt weiterhin trockenes
wetter bei höchsten temperaturen von 11
bis 15 grad im nordosten hier sahen
kühlsten aber schauen sie mal nach
südwesten bis 23 grad geht es da hoch
temperaturen im westen meist um die 20
grad marke die kommenden tage es wird
wärmer mittwoch bis 24 grad aber im nord
westen eine kaltfront mit schauern und
gewittern ein schöner abend